this is a production of Cornell
University
hi this is Frank Rossi for the Cornell
turfgrass video log and today we're
thinking about sidewalk edges edges of
the sidewalk that are very difficult to
maintain turf on and then over the
season if not properly recovered from
lead to significant problems with things
like prostate knotweed and crab grass
oftentimes people will come along and
try to put a pre-emergent herbicide
along the edge and in fact what they
need to do is try to improve that
environment to grow healthy turf
first you have to understand the problem
is likely multi-dimensional potential
salt damage to turf and soil ice buildup
but most importantly we believe that
it's vehicle traffic that causes most of
the problem as seen here where we have
trees along the edge we create a barrier
at least a visual barrier that shifts
the vehicle away from the edge and also
in this image you see that the mounded
slightly mound that edge of the turf
also sorcerer's for preventing water
buildup and also from not making it easy
for that vehicle to travel over there so
because I think it's primarily a soil
problem my observation is that solving
the soil problem and properly grading
our solutions so it's important to
loosen the soil and incorporate either
new top soil or something to amend that
such as a compost grade the edge so that
the vehicle can't easily drive on and
again you don't want too much of a mound
but a slight mound that pushes the
tractor and allows the water not to
settle there is ideal and then you can
seed or sod with a slightly more
salt-tolerant turf such as perennial
ryegrass or tall fescue it's Frank Rossi
for the Cornell turfgrass program this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu